hi this is Proctor in this video we're
going to discuss why cherry picking is
probably not a good idea in the NBA
we're going to do a very simplified form
of analysis and we're going to make some
unrealistic assumptions but they'll be
good enough to illustrate the main point
the average play in the NBA will be in
the halfcourt and it'll have five on the
blue team against five on the red team
if the blue team is running the offense
in an average manner and the red team is
defending then we're going to say blue
scores 45% of the time this is based on
the average field goal percentage in the
NBA the strategy of cherry picking says
that the red team is going to take one
defender and move it all the way to the
other basket so this means the blue team
has a five on four advantage if cherry
picking were to work successfully we can
imagine the red team defends just as
well as if they had five players but the
advantage is that if the blue team
misses the red team can heave the ball
to the other basket and will score 100
percent of the time because the red team
is undefended so in this case blue would
score forty five percent of the time
which is the average red is going to
score 55% because they get all the Blues
misses so cherry picking might actually
work as a strategy and this is pretty
surprising but why won't you see this
what's what could be a problem with it
well we have to use game theory and
think about it strategically so one main
problem is that the blue team is not
going to just accept this situation one
thing the blue team can do is they can
react and they can send a defender
against the cherry picker so now since
both sides have an even number of
offensive players and defensive players
the field goal percentage might go to
the average of 45%
another issue is a blue could simply
copy red strategy so this is known as a
strategy stealing argument so if blue
actually had a disadvantage if it was a
disadvantage to be on possession and
it'd be on offense
then what blue could do is they could
just give red the ball and then they
could be the cherry pickers so this
clearly shows that cherry picking cannot
be a dedicated good strategy and it's
unlikely to work as something a team
does very regularly
however because it's something new I
still would like to see it as a fan and
it'd be interesting to see how it
actually plays out I hope you like this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions on Twitter at
pressure Walker and you can my books
listed on my website